jean paul belmondo lui bat tous les
records d'affluence dans les salles de
cinéma mais il continue de se faire rare
à la télévision
notre vedette nationale tourne en ce
moment un nouveau film aux studios de la
victorine à nice
le film a pour titre joyeuses pâques et
jean paul belmondo a accepté d'en parler
à france roche à laurent du var 11
heures du matin on retourne joyeuses
pâques
jean paul belmondo volant d'un bateau va
escalader la plage casser une capable
est ressorti
pas mal mais
ça s'est très bien passé mais très bien
passé et comme comme spectateur si josi
de compétition je suis un peu frustré
parce que les choses sont pas
suffisamment établis point du cascade
oui c'est l'actuel bail la sortie clos
la montée il faudrait je me demandais ce
jean paul louis
alors ça vous amuse de casser des décors
ah oui ça beaucoup avant de commencer un
film est ce que vous vous dites qu'est
ce que je pourrais bien faire 4 et de
décors ou des voitures
non c'est à dire que quand on arrive dix
ans la partie action là je regarde
évidemment aussi pour voir ce qu'on peut
casser le plus parce que je crois que
les gens aiment bien voir des choses qui
se cassent et moi j'aime bien casser
aussi au cinéma
et quand est ce que vous cachez vous
même au moins j'espère pour casser de
sitôt ça vous est quand même arrivé de
temps en temps et je crois qu'on peut
pas faire des choses ils ont comme ça
sans qu'il y ait des petits pépins mais
j'irai
c'est pas eu des choses très très grave
après j'ai eu des chevilles en l'air des
clavicules mais pas pas le gros pépin
qui m'a empêché j'ai toujours continué
et ça ça m'a permis de continuer avec
une jambe dans le plâtre ou à un poignet
mais s'est pas arrêtée le film un peu
maso une jambe dans le clap
non pas du tout parce que
finalement ça m'aidait pas ce que
c'était un film comique donc ça m'a fait
trop ils démarchent amusant on à
l'inspiration qu'on peut me dire mais je
me demande si c'est la peine de faire
des bêtises pareilles aussi dangereuse
pour arriver à fait rire les gens mais
depuis que j'en fais j'ai accepté et
puis j'ai le deuxième sentiment que j'ai
une peur épouvantable il travaille
toujours avec la même équipe c'est à
dire avec l'équipe de rémy julienne en
particulier et et rémy est quelqu un bon
bain comme vous le savez les américains
nous le prenne pour james bond et ils
n'ont pas tort
l'acteur sur un cascadeur a priori mais
alors lui je pense bien qu'il ait plu
cascadeur qu'acteur ce projet relatif
pour lui parce que le véritablement il
serait à compter dans les cinq meilleurs
cascadeur au monde et 10 a véritablement
une flatterie comment je me sens là je
vais vous dire que je me suis avant je
ne me suis pas sentie parce que j'étais
véritablement pour y aller pour la
gagner mais après
velits jambes en flanelle aux heures et
demie malgré les gens reprennent l on
change les caméras de place quand je
fais que la comédie il me manque quelque
chose et je pense que si je faisais que
des galipettes il me manque là aussi là
donc je j'ai les 2 et donc je suis
prononcé tout jeune j'ai hésité entre
une carrière sportive
ou acteurs et 10 ans avec ce genre de
cinéma je fais les deux donc je suis un
homme comblé
et voilà on repart elle est si certes et
ça vous ça vous excite tout ça vous fait
quand même un peu sort de temps en temps
non ce plutôt excitant je dois dire que
ça me fera croire vraiment ça c'est pour
le plaisir on rallonge comme les
sportifs
notre